okay so are you all physically ready to
lose your goddamn mind like i've
crumbled this up took me and my emotions
on a joyride in so many different ways i
was hyped punching the air sad stoked
mortified terrified literally not
wanting to turn the page because i knew
what was about to happen and completely
and utterly all smacked with a godly
difference in power between what i
thought was strong and the actual or
possible ceiling of power throughout the
world that tatsuki fujimoto has created
this arc here is my absolute favorite of
these stories so far obviously i've got
to say favorite because i know for a
fact that i'll probably lose it when i
get to the control and gun devil arcs
that follow this one but anyway this uk
here is my favorite so far because it
adds an entire new level of depth that
wasn't even considered before like i
honestly did not see it coming at all so
yes finally we have made it to the
infamous international assassins arc
from the very hell of the chainsaw man
universe but quickly just before we do
go any further shout out to fanomaniacs
for actually sponsoring this video and
coming through with a bag for me so as
you can see i look kind of kind of
drippy right now and if you guys want to
have the same kind of drip that i'm
wearing and look as you know as good as
i do on the daily then maybe you should
kind of invest in phantom maniacs and
get some of their drip you know what i
mean like check out these these success
haiku shoes that i'm wearing right now
like watch me run check the speed out i
i couldn't i could never do this
beforehand but now with these shoes from
fandom maniacs man it's absolutely
amazing don't like jokes aside honestly
fano manix is a great company and they
have supported me throughout a lot of my
videos in the past behind the scenes
that you guys don't know about so
honestly i'd really love it if you guys
did support fano maniacs as they have
been supporting me in the past as well
but anyway enough of that let's get back
into the video
so at the end of the last video we had
power conversing into the restaurant
demanding that denji gave her his
flowers that he had originally bought
for resay now we skip forward to inside
of denji's mind while he's having
another nightmare standing in front of
the same door from an earlier nightmare
he once again hears pachita ordering him
to never open the door the next morning
at breakfast denji sits despondently as
power complains about maui's newfound
love of him then she ignores her
thinking of rezay and how his heart was
truly and irreversibly broken by her
this time but when makima later invites
them all on a paid vacation with her his
mood does a complete una reverse gambit
which causes denji to jump with joy aki
and denji instantly agree whilst power
tries to make up an excuse not to go as
they discuss the timing for the trip a
group of devil hunters suddenly enter
the room after conferring with makima
she shows the group a news recording of
the fight against the rezai
explaining the bureau had failed to
censor the broadcast and as such the
chainsaw man's existence has been
revealed to the world power and dingy
ignore this still discussing the
vacation but they are interrupted by
makima who explains that their vocation
was a ruse to explain their absence and
in reality they are going to be put
under protection in order to avoid
assassination by foreign threats then
she reacts with horror as he realizes
that he is going to be restricted and
contained for some time makima asks aki
to be a part of dinji's protection
before telling him that they plan to
hunt the gun devil in the next year and
orders him to not die beforehand aki
thinks back to a conversation he had
with the angel devil who explains the
supposed true nature of devils when a
devil dies they are revived within hell
once they die there they then return to
earth with no memories of the time in
hell he then reveals a secret he asks to
never be repeated that all devils
remember just a single sound from the
moment before they die in hell
the sound of the chainsaw devil
meanwhile in america a trio of part-time
devil hunters sit and discuss their new
job killing denji and returning his body
to the us in exchange for 2 million of
those beautiful american buckaroos the
youngest man aldo expresses a fear of
dying however as talked down by the
other two reminding him that the three
of them all brothers survive the gun
devil's onslaught as they prepare to
leave for japan their leader saito
refers to them as immortal
elsewhere in a forest a woman and a
young man named tolka hunts a fox as he
shoots the fox the woman asks if he felt
like he'd taken the fox's life but the
man explains that he did not as he skins
the animal she asks him again and again
he says no
as he cooks it and serves it to her she
asks again once more and yet again he
denies it the woman then explains that
they will be going to japan and doing
the same to a young 16 year old boy
named denji the man referring to the
woman as master agrees hoping to earn
the woman a retirement due to her short
life span meanwhile in china the hella
sikiseki fun time takes place between a
woman named quan shi and a harim of i
guess you could say friends as they
start nutting a man arrives requesting
her to take the job of capturing denji
they chainsaw devil and as a reward she
can ask for any wish after consulting
her group she demands basic human rights
and an education for all of them at the
same time mahima discusses quan shi with
kashibe expressing concern over her and
her hareem's abilities as they talk
makima states that the biggest concern
is that of the assassin santa claus from
germany yo ho ho though he is thought to
have died of old age the two are still
cautious as kashibe confirms his
abilities could likely outmatch them
elsewhere in germany a government agent
approaches an old man on a bench and
informs him of the mission to hunt denji
in return the man asks for four children
three for a devil contract and one for
pleasure wait what the what the [__]
does he mean by that like bro chill
um yo like calm down meanwhile alone in
his room dingy lies watching tv sadly
wondering why his heart is so desired
and also why the trip was cancelled
noting the sadness aki affectionately
sits on him explaining that the trip was
merely postponed not cancelled and that
if they're able to damage their
opponents enough then the enemy will
retreat allowing denji to return to his
life as normal denji considering the
idea instead decides to kill all of his
enemies so that he can finally have his
vacation
skipping forward and now at the park
both dingy and power eat snacks while
watching some birds and talking about
whether it's okay to eat the
still-living ducks dingy accidentally
drops his food but as he goes to pick it
up and eat it he is stopped by a devil
hunter named kusakabe and then chastised
by him kuzukabe warns him of germs and
food poisoning but then she grows more
frustrated as obviously our man's from
the gutter aki and angel yoshida and
tamaoki also all agree that eating the
food would just be straight up stupid
however the forever ignorant dingy
quickly gobbles it down anyway in a
flashback we see the group all
introducing themselves makima explains
to denji that they alongside another
trio of agents will be his personal
security
kusukabe attempts to express his
authority over denji but has met with
our boys typical sarcasm and yawns
elsewhere the hunters tendo caros and
subaru all take ziggy breaks questioning
why they can't simply hide dingy in his
human form subaru explains that the
other devils can actually smell him as
they drive to meet the main group subaru
asks about makima tendo hesitates before
saying there's something he wants to
discuss regarding her before they can
though a set of road spikes are
bizarrely thrown in front of the vehicle
the car swerves in an attempt to miss
them but runs over the spikes and
crashes in the wreckage subaru awakens
just in time to see the three american
boys rolling up outside the vehicle
sadly for subaru and good old floridian
style the americans shoot the three
hunters dead afterwards the elder two
brothers crack jokes about it but aldo
the youngest reacts with horror to the
murders now hiding the bodies satou asks
joey about his feelings on kelling well
joey the anime man stating his only
response to be a mild annoyance and
disgust sato cracks up laughing before
morphing his face to match there of
corroses the three men then discuss his
voice and how it would sound as satou
shifts his tone and accent in an attempt
to match it back with the main crew they
away within a burger restaurant as denji
and power eats power of his denji her
vegetables however kusakabe interrupts
ordering her to finish them off for her
own health the others agree as then she
forces them into her mouth power begins
to sweat choking down a mixture of
vegetables and vomit just then the woman
from the forest walks past the table the
power and frustration over what just
happened runs outside causing the rest
to follow the woman sits at a table with
tolka revealing that she'd stab dingy
three times with a nail in order to
invoke the cursed devil and that only
one more poke is required she entrusts
the final poke to tulka as she begins to
munch into her burger though she
struggles due to her numb hand and weak
senses she is delighted by the
experience elsewhere the violence fiend
and cabinet walk outside she thanks him
for purchasing her an ice cream cone
then questioning his role as the
violence fiend given his friendliness he
explains that he still has a lot of his
human brain left meaning that he still
holds a lot of his early human memories
however he has no memories whatsoever of
his death only that he was saved by
mahima suddenly a car pulls up beside
them and inside the american bad boy
sato now disguised as kuros gets out he
then tells the two to report tendo and
subaru's death to hq before quietly
commenting to himself on their obvious
gullibility later on dingy and power
said exhausted after a day of constant
movement then she bitterly comments that
rather than being protected he is
instead being used as bait to draw out
the enemy to which aki actually confirms
he promises denji his trip calming him
however power is still furious
aki promises her one reward for her
cooperation with her requesting to drain
a human of their blood to the point that
they die
aki pauses for a moment and then agrees
to let her drain dingy but he
immediately protests yet he is quickly
silenced by power jumping on his
shoulders and screaming with the
excitement of a literal cannibal the
violence fan kabini and the disguised
american bad boy drive over to meet with
the main group american bad boy i'm just
saying that because he's the only like
westerner i think on this entire show so
far so i'm giving you give the
westerners some rep you know what i mean
like gunslinging american bad boy don't
worry about me anyway they tried to eat
the rest of the group aki speaks with
the brother disguised as kuros asking
him to reconsider his place on the
mission however he lies claiming he
wishes to avenge tendo and subaru as
they continue talking power is
distracted by kabini's car
in her typical powerful fashion she
flies into the front seat lying about
having a driver's license and claiming
that the car is actually hers and was
stolen by kabini though kabine quietly
protests it she is silenced by power
sherily threatening her asking if she
wants the car to be washed in her blood
outside the vehicle as the fake heroes
suspiciously introduces himself to dingy
trying to be hella touchy and shake his
hand power suddenly jolts the car
forward ramming into both of them and
actually murking the disguised american
as the group all reacts with horror and
power attempts to blame kabini for the
incident kusakabe suddenly calls out
pointing at the brothers disguise which
is now slipping away revealing his true
face tamaoki recognises him warning the
others of his contract with his skin
devil and the likelihood of his brothers
also being nearby
aki turns to power who though previously
panicking and blaming kabini quickly
begins to claim she knew the truth all
along stating that the glory is all hers
while and the car kabini remains
sweating and sobbing in horror close by
two civilians are shown to be watching
the scene in terror they move to an
alleyway as not to be seen and it is
revealed that they are the americans
joey and aldo in disguise aldo vomits as
joey attempts to collect himself and
come up with a plan however he is
suddenly pulled around a corner by an
unseen figure and is seemingly vaporized
aldo quickly composes himself as yoshida
a devil hunter walks around the corner
having swiftly executed joey noting
aldo's vomit he writes him off as a
bystander and leaves quietly muttering
that a pro wouldn't puke
somewhere in tokyo a car rams into
another as one driver leans his head out
to confront the other here's met by
cosmo who cheerily repeats the phrase
halloween to him the driver slowly
begins to repeat the phrase to himself
over and over quan shi appears and
begins leading cosmo and the other girls
in her group away noticing a sushi
restaurant pingasy grows excited as they
enter the staff express fear of the
group but begin serving them either way
as cosmo makes them repeat halloween too
whilst they wait for their food pingasty
another member of the group begins to
list off facts about fish and long takes
a bite out of a ceramic plate then
stating she is exhausted quan she
instead decides to hunt denchi the next
day oh my
i think is how you say it properly and
quan she uh like her group's names are
so hard to say like my brain though like
literally cut cope try to say them
i try so hard elsewhere aldu observes a
photo of carroz tendo and their friend
tomono disguising himself as kuros he
goes to tomino's apartments who invites
him inside sitting down together he asks
of tomino's life tomino goes on to
reveal that he has few relatives or
acquaintances who barely ever check up
on him he then begins to ask questions
regarding carroz's life revealing that
carols had a girlfriend and a mother
both of whom who cared deeply about him
aldo turned and sees a photo of a young
rose as part of a soccer team seeing
this he breaks down repeating i'm sorry
much to domino's bewilderment
later as the two lie down to sleep
tomorrow speaks to carroz still not
realising as the disguised aldo he
invites him to quit devil hunting and
open up a small clothing shop instead
then bringing up carroz's deceased older
brother asking him what would he say
about carroz's current position then
thinking on his brothers aldo realizes
the advice they would give him would be
a pro always gets his job done the next
day in a crowded street in japan the
mysterious old german man is seen
touching a passerby on the shoulder the
duty touched then gasps and grabs out
that he passed by next to them and so
forth until the entire street had linked
itself converting into doll-like
creatures along the way
throughout the cities the four different
groups tulka and huharim aldo the
elderly man and quan shi all prepare in
various ways to begin hunting the
chainsaw devil
elsewhere in a building makima walks
through a cluster of doll-like corpses
she orders beam and prince to go and
protect genji whilst making the
protection of the other hunters only a
secondary objective at a department
store the creepy old dude watches denji
and the others through a window from a
distance he commands his dolls to attack
the group once they enter the building
following the party inside the doll's
arms warp into blades however as they
enter through the door kusakabe is
revealed to be crouching inside of a
ritual circle then using the power of
the stone devil he petrifies the
approaching dolls yoshida explains the
power of the doll devil stay seen that
if they touch any part of a person
including the clothes that they wear
they will be transformed into a
subservient doll as aki suggests that
there would be a limit to the amount
that could be made a large swarm of
dolls instantaneously burst through the
windows charging towards the group
as they run to the second floor
power suddenly grabbed as her and dingy
rip their dolls to paces kusakabe
reveals that things are likely and
luckily immune to the dull devil's
powers as more swarm a hunter named
nakamura suddenly appears summoning the
fox devil to swipe them away bro this
guy's probably going to die as we know
who every single fox devil use of this
this dude just leaves when he starts
getting attacked too hard tama oki
explains to everyone that there were
hunters stationed in every building and
the street and that the mission's true
purpose was to hunt the assassin
creating the dolls called santa claus
explaining that those turned into dolls
can never be restored he notes that the
ability is short-ranged meaning that the
assassin is in the nearby vicinity and
apologizes to denji for using him as
bait over with the woman she sits at a
nearby park waiting close by tulka
clutches his nail preparing to use it on
dng in the bathroom of the department
store aldo sits psyching himself up for
the coming conflicts the elderly man
summons another swarm of dolls to attack
as kabini attempts to repair the dent in
her car and quan she finally prepares to
hunt
it's just a free for right now i love
this part of the story so much as more
dolls are created by the old man they
begin flowing inside the store dodging
the fox devil swipes and lunging forward
angel summons one of his weapons using
five years worth of his lifespan that he
had absorbed from humans then strikes
down several of the approaching dolls
when questioned as to why he had used
such a weapon earlier he responds that
he has his reasons
outside a group of devil hunters appear
preparing to aid the group however they
are halted by the appearance of quan shi
and uharim as they prepare to attack the
girls quan shi pulls out a sword and
dashes forward making her way to the
second floor of the building in almost
an instant dropping the now dented
swords she draws two more as the hunters
and dolls are revealed to have been
sliced apart having seen a vision of the
events through his future site ike warns
the others as he and the angel devil are
barely able to block her continued
attacks being knocked to the floor
nakamura who was too slow to react is
decapitated by her barrage i told you
this man would die quan she then stands
up looking back at a concerned dingy and
power
outside members of quanchi's team white
destroying the remaining dolls suddenly
they are approached by kashibe kabini
and the violence theme pingasty uses her
ability to see that kashibe has
contracts with the needle claw and knife
devils before assessing him as harmless
due to his lack of body parts with which
he hasn't already made contracts kishibe
slowly strikes towards them as they
prepare to fight
inside the building aki's group reacted
quan shi's instantaneous attacks in a
flash she kicks denji into the air
before knocking out kusakabe and tamaoki
moving towards yoshida he summons the
octopus devil to absorb the brunt of the
attack before spraying the rest of the
room with a mist of ink attempting to
take it by surprise yoshida moves behind
kwon shi but is quickly knocked down but
before she can kill him kishibe
intervenes having already taken long and
pingasty host stage kishibe orders denji
and power to restrain the hostages as
para reveals that she was actually just
playing dead the entire time kishibe and
kuan shi who are revealed to actually be
past acquaintances sit down to discuss
the situation kishibe begins to discuss
retirement and old age however as he
speaks he holds up notes in a notepad
that reveal makima is listening to them
through his notepad he promises to give
kwanshi freedom in return for helping
kill makima kwon shi refuses explaining
through a seemingly unrelated anecdote
that she prefers not to get involved
stating that ignorance is bliss as she
says this aldo enters and shoots at
denji koshibay kickstinji though causing
the attack to miss but long is still
able to take the opportunity to grapple
him and free herself then in a flash
both quan shi and kishibe move to slice
each other's throats
after a few strikes kwon shi is able to
throw koshibe out of the window but he
is able to slow his fool by sliding down
the building's exterior and falling atop
of kabini's car
aldo continues to fire at the various
combatants leaping out of the way of a
fireball shot by long however quanchi
grabs him and throws him through the
window as well with him also falling and
landing on kabini's car inside of the
building the violet scene continues
fighting of a swarm of dolls as kabini
looks down in complete horror at the
state of a destroyed vehicle power still
holding pingasty hostage demands that
quan shi leave her and denchi alone kwon
shi politely asks power to stand down
promising her safety which causes her to
hesitate suddenly our boy beam emerges
from the floor knocking back long and
freeing dingy from her grasp as denji
chooses to flee quan shi is stopped by
yushida who requests a rematch
they two begin to spa rapidly dodging
one another's blows but still landing a
few solid hits on one another yoshida
comments that quan shi is likely not
human due to her minimal reaction to
several devastating blows meanwhile
dingy and beam flee with beam advising
him not to waste blood by turning into
his chainsaw form as they run denji
accidentally stands on tolka's nail and
is suddenly whisked into the air as they
both react with shock and confusion
denji is ripped apart by the cursed
devil before tolker appears and kicks
bean to the ground as denji and beam lay
unconscious the woman appears and
applauds tulku's work however ignoring
tulka's concerns of moving the body the
woman begins to explain the secrets of
making a perfect doll she says by
gathering the trust respect worship and
pity of an individual over a period of
time before converting them you can make
the perfect dole with that she then
transforms him revealing that she in
fact is the real santa claus and that
that elderly man was merely another
perfect doll controlled by her as aki
and the other hunters awaken quan shi
best yoshida and throws him through a
window as he falls he is able to catch
himself with the octopus devil back
inside the others prepare to fight until
aki suddenly stops horrified and
confused by his future vision from
outside santa claus sacrifices the
elderly man and three children that he
had promised to the hell devil in return
for sending every living person within
the building to hell those inside the
building are all of a sudden plunged
into pitch black darkness as those
outside are horrified to see a giant
six-fingered hand reach down and
seemingly crush the building
those who are inside the building then
quickly appear in a large grassy field
with the sky completely covered and
thousands of various doors all moving
throughout the ear this
is hell
as the group survey their surroundings
in hell aki kicks denji awake
immediately deji reactivatedly begins to
transform but is only able to make the
tip of the chainsaw appear from his head
due to the fact that he is low on blood
quan she requests their truce among the
various parties whilst they try to
figure out their current situation she
turns and notes that the fiends power
long pingasty and violence are all
suffering nervous breakdowns aki asks
the angel devil of their current
situation to which angel in an
absolutely petrified daze explains that
they are in hell
quan shi asks pingasty if they have
means of an escape however pingasy
frightenly explains that they are being
watched by devils with a power far
greater than that of the gun devil the
primal fears whom have never died
in desperation pingasy asks permission
to commit suicide only to weep as she is
refused by quan she she cries out as one
of the doors opens and a black drop of
liquid falls out towards the ground
as it does so it symbols the entrance of
the darkness devil the group ready
themselves to fight and as darkness
surrounds them a row of bisected
astronauts appear and a moment quicker
than light itself the darkness devil
moves past them all detaching each and
every single arm from all of their
bodies each person reacts with shock
falling to the ground and bleeding from
their exposed wounds as tulka now fully
under santa clause's control offers the
darkness devil a proposition
denji's heart in return for the power to
kill
makima now flashing outside of hell
santa claus receives a small fragment of
the darkness devil's flesh then proceeds
to swallow it whole as the darkness
devil accepts santa claus's deal it
picks up tolka and rips him apart
kusakabe attempts to utilize this stone
devil's power to fight however the
darkness devil merely grabs the stone
devil and crushes it killing kusakabe
while this happens beam using blood from
his seventh arms revives denji before
being split into pieces by the darkness
devil and killed like i
i'm being followed i'm freaking serious
here
you're about to lose it
same beam's corpse quan shi and tamaoki
prepare to attack however are also
mutilated alongside power long and
pingasy
seeing this the petrified violence fiend
asks kabini to remove his mask he then
attacks with a kick however before he
can hit the darkness devil it speaks in
an unknown language and his body is
blasted with multiple holes denji now
transformed then lunges to attack but
before he can make contact all of his
bones are crushed and snapped which
makes him crumple to the ground as aki
observes power's unconscious body he is
reminded of amino and collapses
muttering i
not again i
still alive the violence thing attacks
once more but is impaled by a sick
ass-looking renaissance blade on
steroids that are suddenly summoned by
the darkness devil as the fiend's blood
reigns down the darkness devil crouches
looming over archie as the angel devil
looks on too scared to even move the
darkness devil slowly turns to look at
him he then randomly begins to bleed
from his eyes nose and mouth before
collapsing to the floor ahi likewise
begins to bleed as the darkness devil
reaches out to touch him suddenly prince
appears grabbing at the darkness devil
but like all of the others before she
can make contact she too is absolutely
dominated quickly communicating with
machima though prince is ordered to
summon her to hell what she tries to
stop but makima commands her she follows
these orders and makima emerges both her
and the darkness devil then face each
other quickly snapping their fingers in
each other's directions makima's finger
suddenly snaps as the various mouths of
the darkness devil erupt with blood
makima approaches tulka's body placing
her hand on his decapitated head then
holding her arm out her bones are slowly
twisted and cracked as the darkness
devil summons a sword to impale her as
makima touches his head tolker offers
all of himself to the hell devil in
return for sending them all back just
then as quickly as they all entered they
are all transported back to the rooftop
of the theme park santa claus was
stationed at as this happens santa claus
absorbs her remaining dolls transforming
into a tall multi-armed creature she
begins to approach makima taunting her
while making my holds denji's torso and
now having given him some of her blood
pulls his cord she then explains that
with the darkness devil's flesh no
attacks and the dark will have any
effect on her however makima asks denji
if he will save her to which he responds
having transformed with an aggressive
woof before charging into battle kashibe
and yoshida sit outside finishing off
the remaining dolls they discuss makima
and acknowledge that she has submitteria
motivations to her actions beyond that
of the bureau as kishibe asks whether
she can hear them yoshida explains that
she currently isn't as none of her
subservients are nearby going on to say
that she can only borrow the ears of
lower life forms such as rats or birds
back on the rooftop denji slices through
santa claus's arm angrily yelling at her
about placing power and the others in
danger moving through a shadow santa
claus is able to instantaneously heal
herself and blasts dingy through the
floor dingy gets up lunging at her but
is knocked back by another swarm of
dolls sugar huggy looks on while
clutching kwon she's seven head then
removing her eye patch and reaching
inside of the socket she yanks out a
long arrow-like blade before dropping
the head into the swarm attacking denji
the dolls are suddenly torn apart as
kwonji appears revived in her hybrid
form proving that she also wasn't human
kanji agrees to fight alongside denji in
order to avenge long and pinasty before
suddenly vanishing over in a nearby
alleyway quanchi appears in front of
santa claus blasting her with powerful
bolts however just as quickly as she is
torn apart she heals herself and
congratulates kwon shi on her moniker as
the first devil hunter wondering how to
attack quan she whom is moving at speed
she cannot register santa claus suddenly
returns the humanity to her dolls
restoring their minds whilst forcing
them to continue the assault as dingy
stares at the now frightened and
screaming human dolls charging towards
him he exasperately shouts there's some
real villain [__] right there now faced
with the emotional human dolls then she
chooses to run away but his attempts to
escape are blocked and he is forced to
impale one of the dolls with his
chainsaw feeling guilty over this dingy
holds back allowing the other dolls to
gradually swarm him suddenly kwon shi
appears shooting the remaining dolls to
pieces she tells dingy that their dolls
are merely imitating humans then she
asks how sure she is to which she
responds that believing it is the only
way he'll be able to bring himself to
kill them reminding him their ignorance
is bliss taking this moment to pause
santa claus bursts through a wall and
grabs quan shi however is once again
torn apart by her blasts looking up kwon
shi realizes that night has fallen
within newfound darkness enhancing santa
claus's powers even further santa claus
moves forward and hits denji towards the
gas station whilst grabbing the various
bulbs fired by quan shi out of the air
quan she turns seeing that santa claus
has turned along and pingasy's corpses
into dolls and taken sugahagi hostage
unable to bring herself to fight them
quan shi is stabbed through the chest by
the pingasty doll which causes santa
claus to wonder whether she could turn
quan she into a doll as well
suddenly denji emerges coasting himself
in gasoline then wrapping his chainsaws
together he creates a spark igniting
himself on fire leaping towards a
surprise santa claus he begins to tear
into her body as she lets out a series
of pained cries
dengy and santa claus both writhe in
pain as dingy complains about the heat
of his flaming body pushing him back
santa claus heals herself instantly
mocking dingy for his foolishness dingy
retorts claiming to watch a great amount
of educational programming before
revealing the chain of his chainsaw to
be wrapped around santa claus's body
using it to keep himself close he lunges
again slicing into her she comments on
the futility of his actions as she
splits the pain and damage between her
various dolls however dingy comments
that her regeneration has begun to slow
due to the light from his flames
suddenly santa claus slams deji into a
wall as a numerous number of dolls break
through and begin stabbing him in the
back santa claus then chooses to wait
and watch dingy burn and die from blood
loss calling him machima's dog however
dingy instead tears into the dolls and
drinks their blood to rejuvenate himself
he tries to move forward only to once
again be swarmed by dolls as santa
mockingly tells him that he will be
reunited with makima in death suddenly
denji begins to pull on his chain
dragging santa claus towards him as he
ignores the blows from countless dolls
around him growing more worried santa
claus orders her dolls to keep her away
from him pulling against the chain and a
tug of war a pair of dolls and a car
then comes speeding around the corner
slamming into dingy and causing a
massive explosion but still denji
emerges from the wreckage cloaked
entirely in flames having not stopped
pulling on the chain
in shock and horror santa claus
questions the extent of his power and
denji proudly reveals his motivation to
still be going on the holiday with
mahima hoisting santa claus into the ear
denji flings her towards himself before
tearing through her and ripping her body
to pieces as she begins to reform then
she grabs the remains of the burning car
and slams them down on her causing a
second explosion which rips through her
body turning her into nothing but a
smoldering mess
as dingy heals himself with some of the
doll's blood santa begins threatening
him revealing that she has armies of
dolls stationed across the entire planet
and along with the power of the darkness
devil will be able to hunt him and
everyone he cares about forever making
his life a living hell
but denji cockingly reminds her of his
immortality before he is suddenly and
surprisingly decapitated by quan she
quan she then asks cosmo to use her
power on santa claus because while the
conflicts had been going on she was just
wandering around this city on her own
waiting for this moment flashing to
within her own mind santa claus suddenly
awakens standing inside an endless
library
she sees cosmo sitting at a nearby table
and comments on the futility of using
psychological attacks against her due to
her mind being linked to dolls across
the world cosmo looking up introduces
herself as the cosmos theme before
explaining the extent of her power the
ability to grant individuals total and
complete understanding of everything in
the universe a process so overwhelming
that the victim is forced into a
semi-conscious state where they are only
able to process the word halloween over
and over again until their death as
santa claus suddenly finds herself
falling through the library her body is
shown in the real world crumbling to
dust as it mutters the word halloween
over and over yoshida and kishibe then
arrive as kwanshi turns to fight them
silently though the two put on
blindfolds and makima emerges from
between them holding a sword
seeing this quanchi instantly surrenders
offering makima anything in return for
sparing the lives of her underlings
makima doesn't even listen to her though
and ignores their pleas before quickly
slicing all three of their heads off in
one swoop elsewhere a news anchor
reports on the dole station throughout
the world who have been locked into sane
halloween as a result of the cosmos
fiend's power amongst them aldo is seen
also shuffling around and repeating
halloween with an obvious pain in his
eyes
back at the main location yoshida
removes his blindfold questioning why
kishibe doesn't want to do the same to
which he simply replies that he doesn't
want to see a damn thing
okay
so
what the [__] that arc there was kind of
insane man i'm looking like the
international assassin arc has been or
assassin's arc has been absolutely
mental i i honestly never ever expected
this i've seen some of the panels
beforehand like the the aki panel on top
of the rooftop or the hell panel with
all the thousands of doors throughout
the sky but i had no idea that it was
going to be to this level of absolute
destruction that was going to go down
throughout this world and actually
happen in this battle with
like tons of main characters just dying
well not main characters i guess you
could say there were third-rate hunters
or whatever i guess you could say as
joshita also put it as well right at the
end there saying he was a third-rate
hunter so obviously i'm wondering what's
in store if he's third rate and kishibe
could possibly be 4-3 even though he
said he's the strongest
what possibly is going to happen next
arc and
what is behind dingy's door it started
right out at the beginning of this arc
with denji you know having that dream
again of the cheetah not telling him to
open the door and i'm just like yo what
is behind that door dingy i feel like
when he opens that door up
it's just going to be utter destruction
on this planet like literally nothing is
going to be able to stop him he's the
reason that like all of the devils in
hell end up coming back to the earth is
like kind of like my uh perception of
like what happens and and what not from
what we got from angel so
where's this mad strength you know we
saw some of it here with this just like
uncanny way that he beat the uh the
devil and whatnot but honestly i can't
wait to see the strength that this man
possibly has in the next arc but
obviously if you guys have enjoyed this
video and want to see more stuff like
this because this video has taken me
absolutely ages to do i've tried putting
a bit more effort into it doing a few
more of those like nice little
animations here and there then make sure
you hit that subscribe button and uh
obviously you know leave a like on the
video as well as it really helps with
pushing my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people and also means i can you
know continue to upgrade the the area
that i do videos and the quality that i
make videos in as i've actually just
bought a standing desk which is crazy
anyway in the next dark it's probably
going to get a lot crazier and honestly
i can't wait to get into it but anyway
for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i will see you
all in april
bye